un vector es algo que tiene tanto
magnitud como dirección entonces un
vector tienen tanto magnitud como
dirección y bueno vamos a pensar en
algunos ejemplos de que sería y que no
sería un vector si alguien te dice que
algo lo que sea se mueve a 5 millas por
hora esto solamente es una cantidad pero
no representa a un vector o sea no no
especifica específica una magnitud pero
no sabemos en qué dirección está
viajando eso a 5 millas por hora esto es
a lo que nos referimos por rapidez está
esto es una cantidad de rapidez y se le
considera como una escalar
esto es un escalar si queremos que sea
un vector debemos darle dirección a esto
entonces tal vez alguien te diga que
algo viaja 5 millas por hora al al esté
así que cinco millas por hora al este
esto está combinación a cinco millas por
hora al este si es un vector esto es un
vector y ya no es rapidez sino velocidad
velocidad entonces la velocidad es un
vector
estamos especificando una magnitud cinco
millas por hora y la dirección de esa
magnitud al este pero como podemos
visualizar esto nos importa eso también
así que bueno digamos que estamos
operando en dos dimensiones y lo lindo
de álgebra lineal es que podemos podemos
aplicar esto a dos dimensiones oa tres
dimensiones o incluso a más dimensiones
aunque nuestro cerebro ya no puede
visualizar digamos cinco dimensiones
pero la matemática nos ayuda a
representarlo
aunque bueno regresemos a nuestro vector
original nuestro vector de dos
dimensiones tenemos que que tiene
magnitud cinco millas por hora y viaja
al este entonces digamos que las
unidades están en manillas por hora en
millas por hora están las unidades y
viaja a lester representado por la
flecha esta flecha a la derecha así que
tenemos
5 de este vector entonces digamos que
esa es la magnitud del vector
digamos 1 2 3 4 5 esta flecha que apunta
en el eje a en el eje bueno a la
dirección positiva del eje de las equis
digamos que esta dirección es este esa
es la dirección este y ok entonces esto
sería este digamos que para acá está el
oeste la otra dirección el norte y lo
que es el sur ahora recuerda que en los
vectores solamente nos importa nos
interesa la magnitud y la dirección así
que este vector tiene magnitud 5 y va en
dirección este pero lo podríamos
representar también de esta otra manera
a la posición en realidad no importa
éste también tiene es un vector de
magnitud 5 y su dirección es el este así
que prácticamente son el mismo vector
estos dos vectores y si lo quieres a
este vector si te preguntas bueno y como
lo represento matemáticamente para poder
hacer operaciones sumar multiplicar lo
que sea con él
bueno la manera típica de hacerlo si tú
quieres representarlo lo puedes hacer
con una variable una variable en
minúscula y le pones una una flecha
arriba que indica o especifica qué es un
vector del que estamos hablando y bueno
este va en cinco millas por hora al este
como representamos eso la típica manera
es usar 22 números tal que uno te diga
bueno usar uno para cada dimensión
entonces uno te va a decir la magnitud y
otro la dirección por ejemplo aquí sólo
estamos usando la dirección horizontal
no la dirección vertical digamos ok aquí
nos estamos moviendo cinco unidades en
el eje de las equis pero no nos estamos
moviendo en el eje de las 10 en la
dirección vertical cierto entonces así
se especifica este y la anotación puede
cambiar por ejemplo en el contexto de
álgebra lineal a la notación del vector
columna es lo más utilizado ponemos 5 y
0 es el mismo vector en la primera
coordenada representa la distancia que
nos movemos en el eje horizontal y la
segunda coordenada
presenta la distancia que nos movemos en
el eje vertical pero es el mismo vector
solo es otra anotación ahora este vector
es algo aburrido cierto 50 qué tal si le
ponemos un vector que se mueve a 3 en el
eje en el eje horizontal y 4 en el eje
vertical como se vería este vector el
vector 34 quedaría más o menos por aquí
el vector 3,4 se ve más o menos así
entonces ahí tenemos otro vector y este
vector lo podemos nombrar no sé a puedes
notar que el vector a se está moviendo
tres espacios o tres unidades
en el eje en el eje horizontal cierto
está trasladándose tres unidades en el
eje horizontal y cuatro unidades en el
eje vertical como puedes ver eso eso es
el vector a y puedes ver que que este
vector entonces lo obtuvimos como
moviéndonos en el eje en el eje
horizontal tres espacios sin el eje
vertical cuatro espacios iniciamos del
origen y llegamos a
de la flecha eso es el vector 34 es el
vector 34 y de hecho puedes usar el
teorema de pitágoras para saber cuánto
mide la magnitud aunque ya sabemos que
es 5 porque la raíz cuadrada de 3 al
cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado es igual a 5
y en álgebra lineal o cuando avancemos
en otros vídeos vamos a ver que podemos
usar más dimensiones
y podemos visualizar hasta la tercera
dimensión porque la cuarta ya es un poco
más difícil y no se diga de la quinta
sexta y todas las demás pero bueno es
todo